we join conservation teams to search for
the endangered pink dolphin
with less traffic in these waters
because of the coronavirus pandemic
they're trying to find out if the
mammals are returning to their historic
habitat
around hong kong we travel through areas
where high-speed ferries used to
crisscross
taking passengers from the city to macau
and mainland china
there are few vessels in sight due to
the travel restrictions
it's been like this for months in a
network of locations throughout this
region
we've got what are called hydrophones so
they're listening
to the underwater soundscape and
recording that in a pre-established
pattern
the low levels of sea traffic have given
scientists a unique opportunity to
understand the impact of noise from
shipping and vessels
after a few hours we reached the coast
of lantau island
developing rapidly yet a key ecosystem
for the dolphins
and we spot them
they are officially known here as the
chinese white dolphins but they turn
pink when their blood pumps through the
vessels near the surface of their skin
so today we saw about six to eight
dolphins and we saw a mix of young and
old individuals and they were engaging
in a very variety of behaviors so not
just feeding not just traveling they did
everything they were
socializing they were jumping up in the
air it shows they are not stressed
and so more likely to breed it gives
weight to claims that there have been
more sightings since the pandemic
it's a glimmer of hope the population of
the dolphins has
dropped by more than 80 percent in the
past 15 years
one of the main reasons major
infrastructure and reclamation projects
like hong kong airport's third runway
and now with this study
scientists can also show the impact of
underwater noise
they hope their findings will push the
government to take action
we're not saying we want the high-speed
ferries to stop
we're saying that we would just like
them to take account
of this prime habitat area for example
by just changing their course slightly
or traveling more slowly it's estimated
around two thousand of these dolphins
are left in the wild
around the world there have been more
sightings of endangered animals due to
the limited movement of the human
population
and the lockdowns imposed by the
pandemic it's a stark reminder of the
impact we have on nature and also shows
that there still is a lot more we can do
to protect the planet
and help the environment recover
divigopalan al jazeera hong kong